for much of the past two millennia the
commonly held
belief was that disease deformities and
other ailments
were caused by some sort of toxic
exposure
of some noxious and dirty stuff
infiltrating our bodies
and making us sick the ancient romans
had a name for it
they called it miasma which meant bad
air
they believed miasma emanated from the
ground or from the breath of snakes and
other poisonous animals
if we were exposed to too much of it we
might get a skin disease or bubonic
plague maybe we'd get
leprosy or crooked teeth so human
sickness was
spread through these huge clouds of
poisonous air
this my asthma theory stuck around until
around the late 1700s
when a dutch drape shop owner named
anthony
van leeuwenhoek began collecting glass
lenses in a metal tube
constructing the first super powerful
microscope lewinhoke intended to use
this device to inspect the thread he was
selling in his shop
but after a while he got curious began
inspecting other stuff
skin sperm wood pulp insects and
rainwater
he noticed something extraordinary
festering within substances were these
little
organisms he called them little animals
or animolecules lewinhock determined
that
yes our bodies were being infiltrated by
toxins
and these substances were making us sick
perhaps even deforming us
but it wasn't miasma it was these little
evil
animolecules they would later get a
different name
we would call them germs so germ
paranoia
quickly spread throughout europe people
began covering their mouths and their
bodies and their windows
anything to keep these little beasts
away
but no matter how well populations clean
themselves
no matter how many face masks they wore
people kept getting sick and even
stranger
whole populations started getting sick
with new diseases
nobody had ever seen before that few
had even heard of